وفي المقابل اتهم وزير الخارجيه الروسي
سيرجي لافروف الدول الاوروبيه الموقعه على
معاهده منسك التي سعت لانهاء الحرب في
اقليم دنباس بانها وقعت على المعاهده دون
وجود نيه للالتزام بها واضاف لافروف في
كلمته في جلسه لمجلس الامن بشان حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا ان روسيا وحدها هي من تلتزم
بالمعاهده حسب
تعبيره
تم التوصل الى معاهده منسك وتبنيها عبر
قرار من مجلس الامن الدولي وفي العام
الماضي جميع الموقعين على معاهده منسك على
السيد بوتين وانا اتحدث هنا عن ميركل
وهولاند وبورشين كو صرحوا علنا وبنبره من
السرور بان ليس لديهم النيه لتنفيذها
كانوا ببساطه يحاولون كسب الوقت لرفع
قدرات اوكرانيا العسكريه واعطائها الاسلحه
كي تستخدمها ضد روسيا l